okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology history q a
um i it's been a few weeks since we've
done one of these because the last
couple weeks
both of the wednesdays of the last two
weeks have been
conferences that we've been organizing
uh
which have had at least some historical
content but let me come
back to some questions that have been
asked here let me try and address them
uh there's a question here from nelson
what appeared first in math complex
numbers or vectors
what's the relationship between them
with the square root of negative numbers
be a problem if equations will develop
with vectors instead of regular numbers
okay that's interesting there's a
there's a complicated story of the
emergence of numbers
and different kinds of numbers and so on
in fact i was just at a
conference last week for a little bit
that was talking about
the general concept of numbers and i i
just wrote a
a piece about our numbers inevitable
and uh in in the sense that i think i
started the piece by saying
you know the aliens arrive in a starship
is it inevitable that in order to make a
starship you have to have invented
numbers
or you go to visit some uncontacted
tribe in some jungle somewhere
is it obvious that they will have
numbers
and uh the the answer is
i think there are some things where
there is a certain degree of obviousness
about numbers and somewhere there isn't
but
let's talk a little bit about numbers
the origin of numbers and
uh the emergence of different kinds of
numbers like complex numbers
so one big question is how do people
ever come up with numbers what was the
origination of numbers
we don't know for sure but people
started making tally marks
oh maybe hundreds of thousands of years
ago there are bones with tally marks in
them there are sort of grim things like
you know
the axe which has a notch cut in it but
one suspect
that was uh every victim of whatever
kind
of the acts uh got a notch associated
with them and that that's sort of
counting in unitary
just representing successive numbers by
just like
uh one one one one one uh for for
as you as you uh look at successive
numbers
the question of when there starts being
less more non-trivial notation for
numbers
that's a more complicated issue and i
think that's really the babylonians
are the the folks who really started
dealing with that maybe let's see
maybe four thousand years ago um
and uh there's sort of a question how
many times were numbers invented
in the history of the world it's just
like we know writing was invented you
know
four ish times in the history of the
world with somewhat different
writing systems were numbers invented
only once
because they all seem to kind of work
more or less the same way or they were
they invented multiple times
um that's uh that's a question i don't
think we really know the answer to at
this point
it seems like all the numbers in the
world kind of work more or less the same
way
is that a feature of numbers or is that
a feature of the fact that they were
invented only once
just like the languages of the world
they sort of you know some of them are
alphabetic some of them are ideographic
they sort of have somewhat multiple ways
of working but some features
are com in common but so you know the
origination of numbers
was uh it's
you know what caused numbers to get
serious so to speak
you know i think one of the things i i
mentioned this in this piece that i
wrote last week about numbers
if you are uh sort of out
in the um um
you know just hanging out uh you know
living off things in the jungle or
something
it's not completely obvious that you
have to be a careful counter of things
like you know you have a bunch of dogs
every dog has a name
it's like you have five dogs well i
don't have five dogs i have you know
this this this dog named this this dog
named this and so on and so on and so on
actually i have to say just a footnote
to that i was curious about
writing that that statement about you
know the sort of way
in which one might not need numbers and
i i thought just
just so i know what i'm talking about
let me you know go figure out
uh four uh so-called a-numeric
uh uh groups
groups that don't have uh don't for
example have names for numbers in their
languages have only
names for one and a pair and many and so
on in their languages
i'm just curious what do they call their
pets and so on
and i i then got uh dragged into the the
kind of the
the strange world of pet vocatives um
and the question of what you call animal
vocatives in general
if you are uh you know living in one of
these tribes what is the typical
uh you know do you in fact name animals
or not
and and the answer seemed it's just like
people might ask the question you know
do you name uh you know cats and dogs
yes you do
do you name cows if you're a you know a
dairy farmer or something well maybe you
do maybe you don't
there's a question of when do you name
things individually
uh independently when you count them
with numbers and so on but anyway so the
the answer is that it seems like
anthropologists have studied
pet vocatives and that there are
usually not individual names that
are sort of distinct human-like names
but there are different words that are
used when you address
a cat as opposed to when you refer to a
cat
referential name you know is cat but
when you are addressing the cat it's you
know kitty kitty kitty
type type thing and i was somewhat
interested to see
there are big long lists of you know if
you are addressing a jaguar
this is what you say as opposed to
referring to a jagger and so on okay
that's irrelevant but sort of amusing
um but uh in any case the origination of
kind of the idea of numbers
and the idea that one could have things
like positional notation for numbers
uh lots of stuff came in with the
babylonians partly because the
babylonians
you know mesopotamia was the place where
sort of cities got serious for the first
time
and people started having to organize
things and have definite schemes for
you know property ownership and taxation
and all this kind of stuff
and that led to kind of the let's have a
a definite way of counting sheep let's
have a definite way of having weights
and measures things like that
which drove the need for more sort of
standardized representations of numbers
and so on
and so you know the babylonians had this
base60 scheme
that uh you know we inherit through
hours minutes seconds and so on um
the uh uh and 360 degrees and in um
uh you know in a circle and such like um
but that was that was definitely
integers and some rational numbers
you know when they made tables and
square roots and there were
square roots that didn't come out
reasonably as rational numbers they just
left a blank
there they didn't really have a way to
think about
those kinds of numbers that were not
representable in the
integers in base 60 and some fractions
and so on like the egyptians had the
scheme of
every fraction has to be a sum of
reciprocals it's one half plus one
quarter
plus one sevenths it can't be two tenths
plus
three one hundredths et cetera et cetera
but
um uh you know as one looks at kind of
what happened with numbers
integers rational numbers understood in
antiquity
the concept of uh sort of square roots
and things
kind of understood implicitly through
geometry and so on in antiquity
but i don't think really thought about
as a
thing for which there would be uh very
clear notation and things like that i
mean i was uh
the the ways that numbers got
represented had tended to have a lot of
geometrical entanglement i mean like i
was looking last year at euclid
um and uh trying to understand the
empirical matter mathematics of euclid
and so on
and there are all these pieces and
euclid's elements about
you know to compute the fifth epitome
an opportunity is some kind of number
that
is uh that representable square roots in
this way in that way and the other way
it's somewhat natural when presented
geometrically it's not particularly
natural to us today
with the way mathematics is developed um
represented as
um uh in terms of of of kind of
symbolic notation but anyway the the you
know
in of course there were weird other ways
to represent numbers like
you know the greeks had this way of
representing numbers where they mapped
numbers onto the letters of their
alphabet alpha was one beta was two gam
was three etc
and you know with a number of for
somebody like me who spent my life as a
computational language designer
there are some interesting little
glitches that happened because for
example
they set their numbers mapped to letters
at a particular time
in the history of the developments of
the greek language and so that meant
that letters like sampi and daigamer and
copper
which didn't really make it in sort of
later
greek writings were burnt into the
number system
and because you have to have a character
that represents 60 or whatever it is
and it better be a character that's
still there so to speak even if sampy
has been retired
in terms of ordinary greek writing but
so the greeks used the letters of the
alphabet
as as a way to represent numbers um
then roman numerals much better known
had this somewhat peculiar subtractive
mechanism where unit 9 is
ix and things like this one of the
things that is sort of a long-term
notation matters type story in the
history of mathematics
is i think the invention of algebra was
was slowed down by by centuries
millennia perhaps
by the fact that people represented
numbers using letters
that the greeks had their scheme the
romans had that had their scheme
for where you're fundamentally using
letters of the same kind using words
to represent numbers because if you
wanted to represent an unknown an
x well you wrote down an x but that x
looks just like
the x that represents 10 in roman
numeral system for example
you know euclid had already labeled i
think angles
it's not clear if euclid actually drew
these figures or if they were somewhat
later but
but within the euclidean tradition
people had drawn figures in which they
labeled angles and things
with letters with greek letters and so
on but
for some reason that as a as a matter of
writing down equations and things like
that that didn't really happen
so it was you know
then there was the whole hindu arabic
numeral system
which existed in those parts of the
world
and was brought to the west around 1200
a.d
primarily by leonardo fibonacci um
and you know who wrote this book libra
abachi the book of the abacus
i mean in those days it was sort of a
big business to be a
consultant for merchants and
mathematical consultant for merchants
and that was what fibonacci was
and people would write these these these
books that had titles like you know
the secret way of doing calculation uh
that would allow you to
compute things that you needed as a
merchant and much better than all those
other merchants over there
it's kind of uh quant finance version
0.1 or something
um and so
in any case once they were hindu arabic
numerals there was a different notation
for numbers
as from from from
letters of the alphabet and so less of
the alphabet started to be able to be
used as unknowns
and that was a thing that um uh kind of
came in with people like vieta
in the 1400s i guess starting to bring
in ideas of algebra and so on
because people had had like diaphantus
in the first century a.d
had had um perfectly you know had
written these books
about equations notably about
diophantine equations equations
involving integers but he'd written
about other kinds of equations
but his equations were always written in
terms of words you know and
and uh they were not written in a kind
of mathematical notation
but that started to come in now it's
still the case
in by the 1400s there isn't
uh people it's there aren't negative
numbers people are not talking about
negative numbers people are barely
talking about zero
and they certainly aren't complex
numbers and
the thing that the camel that broke the
hair that whatever that broke the camel
back in this case was the cubic equation
so people knew that uh even in antiquity
people had found out how to solve
quadratic equations you know x squared
you know x squared plus b x plus c and
had found the quadratic formula
cubic equations x cubed etc
much more complicated people hadn't been
able to
solve the cubic and particularly they
hadn't solved the casus irreducibleness
of the cubic
where you would have um uh
and and there's the sort of the question
of is there a solution to the cubic
that involves real numbers or not and
there it you can have with a cubic you
can have one real solution to complex
solutions
you can have uh let's see with real
coefficients
uh i don't think you can have all
complex numbers anyway
so we now get to the end of the 1400s
beginning of the 1500s
and people were sort of struggling to
solve the cubic
and this chap cardano oh it's his first
name
gulliamo cardano forget the first name
uh cardano before it was
the fourth most valuable cryptocurrency
cardano was a person
who lived around 1500 who was primarily
a doctor
and also various other things in those
days you know as
as some of us aspire to today to be
somewhat generalists
in those days that was more of a thing
um and you know cardano was both a
doctor and
an astrologer and a mathematician
and probably various other things
notably he was also a big enthusiast of
personal analytics he recorded
all these different facts about himself
and that was a thing that people did in
those days is
is you know let's recognize when
something good happens in our life
you know is that correlated with the
phase of the moon with the
position of mars and the sky is with is
it correlated with this or that or the
other
and people would kind of record this
personal analytics data
in the hopes that if they could
correlate that for example for their own
lives they could
then essentially become consultants
where they would say well let me
look at what it is for your life then i
can predict whether you should do this
or that make this or that
business decision or whatever based on
that famously cardano is
is said to have predicted the day of his
death i don't know if that's really true
but um uh i think he he has an
autobiography
which begins something like all the good
things that have happened to me in my
life happened
when it was a it wasn't a full moon but
it's some other
astronomical situation so to speak
anyway cardano
uh comes into this and uh there's this
cubic equation to be solved
and there were a number of other people
um
there's a whole there's a whole uh tale
of woe associated with a person called
tartaglia
another person called pierrot
farrow i forget oh gosh
i'm not sure anyway there were there
were these three people and they had
complicated relationships one was a
student of another and
one was some relative of another one
anyway all these people were kind of
battling
to be the one to give the grand
demonstration of i can solve the
cubic equation the one who became most
famous for doing that
was cardano um who wrote this book
called oz magna the great art
of mathematics and so on um and um
he but what did he do to solve the cubic
cubic equations it turns out he needed
two ideas he needed negative numbers and
he needed complex numbers
imaginary numbers square root of minus
one and so on and so very bizarrely in
the history of mathematics those two
ideas
that are taught so separately today
when we teach elementary mathematics
actually arose
in mathematics became accepted in
mathematics around the same time
and both as a result of this fairly
elaborate thing the cubic equation
so so that was kind of the you know
negative numbers got serious at that
time
so did imaginary numbers um
that was long before the invention of
things like vectors
the fact that we can interpret uh
complex numbers as being
numbers you know where where there's a
real and imaginary part and those are
like points in a two-dimensional plane
that idea uh long post states
the um the original invention of
imaginary numbers
um by around the time of cardano around
1500 and so on
the um that whole idea of uh
of sort of the mapping of complex
numbers to these points in the plane
i think that got big with people like
euler in the 1700s
um but again euler wasn't drawing you
know i have a copy of euler's collective
works a very impressive
you know whole shelf of uh opera omnia
you know the
all the works of leonard euler um very
impressive and very
interesting to look at because their
notation is very very modern
i mean in in you know they will be
completely at home in a modern calculus
course so to speak
uh and and uh you know euler was the one
who um
for example introduced well uh certainly
pi i think also i
um pi had been there was a chap called
jones
in england who had come up with the the
notation for pi
but euler is the one who cemented that
notation and really used it widely
but by the time of euler people were
understanding oh that this
there's this notion of you know e to the
i theta and and um
all this kind of thing and and there's
this uh there's some kind of geometrical
correspondence
of complex numbers but the notion of
vectors
didn't come in until much later i mean
the notion of matrices which seems to us
very obvious
you know vectors matrices all those
kinds of things linear algebra and so on
that was a thing of the very late 1800s
i mean and it came in through a lot of
weird theories i mean there was the
theory
so-called determinant theory that was a
big thing that was looked at was
for example arthur cayley was the person
who eventually
introduced basically the idea of
matrices and that was i think in the
1880s maybe
1870s perhaps um and kaylee have been
looking at
uh solutions to equations and whole
sort of the structure of symmetries of
equations all this kind of thing
and that led to both this representation
theory
and okay so-called invariant theory
which was a whole
branch of mathematics that um uh sort of
was related to things like group theory
and so on and related to algebraic
geometry in the end
but it was a it was a kind of a big
thing in the late 1800s
but so this notion that now seems
completely obvious to us of these arrays
of numbers and things
that was a completely unobvious notion
back in the time of uh when when that
was being invented in late 1800s
and i should say that that you know if
we look at this kind of span of
of history the um the idea
of imaginary numbers negative numbers
1500 ish
the idea of decimal numbers of you know
we can represent what we now call a real
number you know something the computer
will be 0.72564
et cetera et cetera et cetera that
didn't come in until the mid-1600s
and what happened there was people there
was a chap called them
baron napier scottish baron who
invented this basically invented
logarithms
and in particular he invented the idea
of so-called napier's bones
which became the basis for the slide
rule where the idea was if you mark the
the if you have this uh uh you know this
pair of
ruler-like things and you mark off
uh the the numbers logarithmically
then you can just when logarithms add
the numbers multiply
and so you can have it be the case that
you just move one of these sort of rule
like things relative to the other
and that will give you multiplication
that's how slide rules work there's a
chat but william outread
i think who invented slide rules in the
1600s
and uh i as a young child sort of
independently invented the addition
slide rule
a rather more elementary idea where you
literally take two rulers
and um you can slide them relative to
each other and that will make you an
addition slide rule
um it's uh uh as when i was
rather young i think there must have
been teachers were very confused about
why in doing math exercises i was always
there with two
two rulers but anyway we'll leave that
as a
as a somehow these things one never
really changes what one does it was
always you know tools for solving things
has been my kind of lifelong activity
but any case the the um the idea
of um uh of kind of
number lines marking things off decimals
you know that logarithms
come in there's a guy called simon
steven in the netherlands
who was i think generally gets credited
with the idea of actually
you know decimal numbers write down the
digits you know point blah blah blah
blah blah
not quite the same as the babylonians or
the egyptians and so on
who'd had these rational rational
fractions and so on
to represent uh uh fractional numbers
but in any case the the um uh the thing
so i think the question was asked was
you know how do vectors relate to the
invention
of complex numbers vectors came uh
centuries
after the invention of complex numbers
and the the sort of the standardization
of vectors
as the thing you really looked at i mean
even when i was a kid
so this is i don't know 1960s or
something
the math books did not routinely talk
about vectors and matrices
the elementary math books would get to
calculus they wouldn't have talked about
vectors and matrices by that point
i think what happened is in the the kind
of
the flowering of linear algebra
particularly happened in well it
happened in pure mathematics
but it also happened in the world at
large in the 1960s when people
started to be able to numerical linear
algebra on computers
and the idea of a raise on computers was
quite natural and arrays of arrays which
made matrices
and then this whole development of all
these methods for finding inverses of
matrices finding
solving matrix equations all that kind
of thing that was the 1960s
to 1970s that really happened in a way
that
is very reminiscent of what's happening
with modern machine learning it was just
a bunch of very detailed specific
uh often sort of hacky seeming
algorithms that by golly went from oh it
was really difficult to solve a system
of linear equations too
it's completely routine it could be
burnt into the hardware of a
of an fpu or something floating point
unit where it can be
built in and it became something that's
very efficient to do
and then a lot of things got built on
top of that in computer graphics and
other areas and so on
so the the kind of something like
vectors that seem very obvious to us
today were not obvious in the history of
mathematics
nobody was using them nobody cared that
wasn't the point
i suppose coordinates did come in people
like descartes for example
we have the cartesian coordinates just
you know cartesian coordinates because
they were invented by descartes
and i don't completely know the
relationship i'm trying to think about
this you know people
drawing geometrical figures where they
had computed the points and were drawing
them on a coordinate grid
i don't think that comes in i'm not
immediately remembering i'm not seeing
not remembering seeing euler doing that
i'm i
suspect by the time of gauss in the
1800s that was being done but i'm not
sure
um you know i think it's it's um
uh yeah so so those are that that's a
little bit on the
on the subject of uh kind of the
origination
of the notion of complex numbers
and then uh you know it's worth
realizing that people
invent new kinds of numbers every so
often like famously
william rowan hamilton invented
quaternions
in the 1840s maybe 1847.
i regularly remember um and there's an
irish chap who
uh who was uh famously you know out and
um you know out walking or maybe on a
horse i'm not sure i think walking
and suddenly has this idea for how
quaternions should work quaternions are
hyper complex numbers instead of just a
single square root of minus one
there's i j k which represent there's
one
ijk and you can represent these
quaternionic numbers
using that and uh he was so proud of
this he kind of carved
the the the key relations for
quaternions in the side of a bridge
which i think is still visible today
but um uh uh hopefully nobody would say
oh my gosh that's terrible you know
graffiti vandalism etc
et cetera the mathematics is lost
forever as a result of that
but any case i think that um uh
you know quaternions were for a while
it's like
oh everything's going to be quaternions
quaternions are amazing you know we're
going to define quaternionic physics
we're going to define
everything's going to be quaternions
didn't really pan out that way
quaternions are actually a useful
representation
of rotations in three-dimensional space
and they're interesting
but they're not kind of the take it away
that's that's how everything works
uh unlike complex numbers which have
turned out to be really pretty central
to lots of kinds of things
you can go beyond quaternions and go to
octonions that's as far as
uh that um type of clifford algebra
no the um oh gosh i'm trying to remember
there's a it only goes as far as the
octanians with certain properties that
you need i mean the
the um uh the quaternions no longer have
commutativity of multiplication the um
tonians no longer have associativity of
multiplication but octonions again
kind of a special special kind of number
that haven't turned out to be
very globally important so it's always
an interesting thing where you see these
different
sort of kinds of numbers or what kinds
of constructs and mathematics are they
going to be globally important or not
another one that came in late 1800s was
transfinite numbers that was georg
cantor's idea
and it's sort of an interesting piece of
mathematical history i mean
cantor was trying to solve a very
practical problem he was trying to look
at
the sums of trigonometric series you say
sine 2x
plus 1 3 sine 3x plus 2
times sine 4x plus whatever you have a
trigonometric series like that
and the question is when you do the sum
for an infinite sum of that kind for
sine
nx times some coefficient for sum for
all n
does that series converge or not and
the domains in which it converges can be
very very elaborate
and so what did canto do he tried to
make a description
of the sets of values for which
there is convergence in trigonometric
series what mathematics did he
did he have to do that well he had to
invent it it was called set theory
and that was how set theory came to be
invented and transfinite numbers
were invented at the same time as part
of the story
of this very practical thing about
finding the convergence of trigonometric
series
subsequently cantor kind of said let's
consider transfinite numbers separately
let's consider set theories separately
and those became
well set theory became a very
foundational theory that people sort of
have often believed is kind of the the
most foundational axiomatic theory for
mathematics
not sure if that's really right but that
is a general belief
uh transfinite numbers did not have such
a happy time
transfinite numbers are are you know the
numbers you get
for example that the the ordinal
trans-finite numbers are the numbers you
get
you know you count one two three four
five and you keep on counting forever
and then you get to then you say what's
the number after what you get to if you
count forever well let's just call it
omega
then you can say well what's the number
after that what's omega plus one
and you can make up a whole theory of
transfinite numbers you get omega to the
omega you get limits when i get to the
omega0
call that epsilon zero and then you get
limits of that and you can build this
whole world of transfinite numbers
and um the question is is that useful
for anything
and the answer is in 100 years it's been
kind of marginal
it's been useful for some things it's
pretty interesting it's mathematically
interesting the structure is interesting
but if we say you know does that relate
to the physical world well actually our
current theory of physics kind of
suggests in the theory of physics that
we've developed in the last year or so
kind of suggests that transfinite
numbers don't really have
a place in our instantiatable physical
universe
but they're nevertheless things you can
study as as conceivable kinds of things
but in any case that that's an example
of uh i think it's just an interesting
feature that you know cantor discovered
something like set theory but by the
time
in the 1960s uh
there had been this effort in
mathematics education that was called
new math
and i'm sure it's there's been a new
math many times in history
but um the new math was supposed to be
sort of a rethinking of what elementary
math should be like i mean
elementary math uh in the textbooks you
know you can see what the babylonians
taught as elementary math
much of it is quite similar the kind of
word problems the babylonians had are
bizarrely similar to the word problems
that um
uh that we have um um uh you know that
people
people solve today um and if you go
through history by the 1600s the first
kind of
somewhat organized math curriculum there
was one i think it's um
crisis hospital school in england if i
remember correctly was the first place
that really had a
sort of organized math curriculum in
that sense and they
they brought in some consultants this
was in the 1600s
they brought in some consultants to help
define this curriculum
and one of those consultants was isaac
newton and um so they got some calculus
in their curriculum as a result of that
or
these fluxion-based calculus perhaps but
in any case the
you know sort of time rolls forward and
and math textbooks
you know they kind of standardize in the
way they standardized
in the 1800s and to 1900s and there was
this kind of idea
let's make a new math because this is
not the right
you know doing arithmetic and things
like that oh that's
old you know let's do something new and
by that time
kind of things like the bubaki school of
french school of very pure mathematics
had uh had come and been been around
and um so people had this idea
mathematics is really something
more than just doing arithmetic and so
on more than just doing algebra
let's bring in new math which brings in
the concept of more advanced mathematics
so the result of that was actually in
the early 60s i guess the mathematics
teaching profession was a lot smaller
than it is now
there was some maybe 62 or something
there were these conferences at harvard
i think
that were sort of defining the new math
and defining what the curriculum should
be
and that led to a curriculum that had as
one of its front and center features
set theory and so this thing that had
gone
from 1880s or whatever this very obscure
thing with transparent numbers and all
that by 1960
it was let's teach this to all school
children and i remember
um when i was um uh sort of
learning math i wasn't a particularly
good school learner of math but
but this must have been 1969 or so
the textbooks all got sort of replaced
with new math textbooks
that had set theory and topology um
and uh in a sense the um set theory is
about intersections and unions and all
this kind of thing
and topology was about doughnuts and
holes well actually
i grew up in england where donuts don't
have holes in them so so that
the topological um uh concept of a donut
with a hole uh so it wasn't really a
thing they were just
donuts at least when i was growing up in
england were just these
these things that had you know jam in
the middle but the jam was
injected into the middle rather than
there being a hole in the middle it was
just a thing homeomorphic to us
um the uh in any case
um well let's see
uh okay there's
there's a whole bunch of other questions
here actually there's a question from
rbs
uh real variables rational numbers
analysis why not just stick to integers
um
you know the maybe i shouldn't get too
deep into this the
the whole question of sort of the
construction of real numbers
that is numbers of arbitrary size rather
than just
integers and um this notion you know
people would say
uh who was it i think it was was it
deadline or somebody else
says um um
you know integers are kind of the work
of god real numbers
are constructed by humans i think i i am
increasingly taking a having a better
understanding of what the foundations of
math should
really should be thought how they should
really be thought about is something
that's very recently emerged for me
as a result of understanding the
relationship between kind of
the fundamental structure of the
physical universe and the fundamental
structure of
metamathical universe something i've
recently been understanding
and i might take a somewhat contrary
view there but the concept of how do you
really construct a real number you know
you might say oh it's really obvious you
just pick you know pick a number you
know you can type in any number you want
well it's not quite as obvious as that
because for example one of the biggest
issues is
is 0.9999999 with all the nines
equal to one point zero zero zero zero
zero
is it equal is it not equal not clear
you know those three things are probably
considered equal even though they're
represented differently
that's the beginning of a whole series
of of complicated issues
about real numbers and about exactly how
they're defined and
for example if you are presented with
two real numbers one of them is square
root of two minus pi
over over you know some uh cube root of
this and blah blah blah blah you have an
expression for that real number
and and then you have another expression
for a real number and you say are those
two expressions equal
well that may be really hard to
determine for integers
if you're dealing with arithmetic
operations for example just do the
arithmetic
and you get the answer it's this integer
you're happy there's just one
representation of it you can easily tell
if it's equal that's not true for real
numbers
that's not true for numbers that aren't
sort of discrete like integers you can
have these different
representations for numbers and telling
whether they're equal or not
is really difficult now what turned out
to be the case
which surprised i think people to some
extent is
if you have an equation to solve and you
say the answer is always integers okay
that's one kind of equation
another thing is you've got this
equation and you can say the answer is
any complex number
or any real number a number with any
number of digits you know
where the digits can go on forever okay
so you might have thought
equations involving real numbers of
complex numbers would be intrinsically
harder to solve
than equations involving integers you
would be wrong about that
what girdle's theorem showed back in
1931 was that among other things it took
many more steps to get to this point
that integer equations
are fundamentally difficult to deal with
it was by late 1960s
before it was fully established that
so-called different time equations
involving integers
that there is no decision procedure if
you ask
does this equation have a solution it
may be arbitrarily hard to answer that
like you could say well i'm just going
to try all the numbers but then maybe
there's no upper bound on how big a
number you'd have to try and sometimes
it might be you know a hundred digit
number or a
thousand digit or a billion digit number
and eventually at the trillion digit
number
boom you've got an answer um
and so it it for differential equations
it is sort of arbitrarily difficult to
answer the question
whether there's a solution in contrast
equations involving real variables uh if
you just restrict it to square roots and
cube roots and you know
radicals and things like that there is a
decision procedure a chap called alfred
tarsky came up with a version of that in
the 1940s i guess
um that there is a systematic way to
just grind through and solve any such
equation
in fact in in language and in
mathematica
we finally made a practical version of
that decision procedure
that we use all the time to solve those
kinds of
systems of of uh of of of
continuous equations of real real number
equations and so on
so the surprise is actually for
equations
real numbers are easier to deal with
than integers but
sort of definitionally it's a lot harder
to deal with real numbers than it is to
do with deal with integers
and i might say that when it comes to
real numbers
the case of radicals is decidable
the case where you can involve
trigonometric functions and so on
this question of is there a way to
figure out what these two things are
equal
again falls into the same questions you
can basically encode
problems that are about integers there
and again you have this
this sort of problem of you might have
to do an infinite computation to get to
the answer
there's a question here from aaron
what's the largest number that i've ever
used in practice in a computation
well i can tell you i've i've
encountered some pretty big numbers in
my time
so there's some stuff i've been doing
recently
having to do with this problem emel
post's problem of tag
where we're just trying to work out does
this thing halt or not
and it's been spending a lot of time on
computers and it's routine to get to 100
trillion
uh now we're getting you know 100
trillion steps and we don't know if it
holds it or not
so i've certainly encountered numbers of
that size where i care about every last
digit of the number
now another thing that's happened is
that i've ended up with a bunch of
numbers that
are generated by tetration so if we go
you know you add ones together you get
you you
let's say you repeatedly add one you
repeatedly add numbers
together you are it's like multiplying
numbers
pleased to multiply numbers together
it's like taking powers you repeatedly
take powers of numbers
it's another kind of operation sometimes
called power towers
sometimes called tetration it's where
you get things like two to the two to
the two to the two to the two et cetera
et cetera et cetera
you get those kinds of towers um yes i
have encountered such towers
those have arisen quite naturally there
are very simple uh
systems that um involve just
uh doing simple sort of symbolic
transformations
that immediately give you these
tetration type numbers
um and uh those numbers can be extremely
big they
they get um and i've i've tried to
figure out even approximately how large
the numbers are and even that
you you quickly run out of being able to
say what are even the first digits in
those numbers and that
that you know those numbers can be
represented as 10 to the 10 to the 10 to
10.
you don't even know if it's 1.5 times 10
to 10
or 6.7 you can't find those leading
digits actually
strangely you can find the trailing
digits often but not the leading digits
so those are those are places where i've
run into some big numbers
and where another another place where
that happens is the whole thing of
touring machines
there can be things where you can say
this machine will halt
but it only halts after this absurdly
long time
that is defined by this number that is
represented
in terms of things like tetration um
okay uh
let's see brian is commenting that
moving from roman numerals to hindu
arabic helped merchants back in the day
absolutely
that's how that's sort of why fibonacci
was sort of a hero at that time
um jonas is asking was tau
used before pi i don't think so so
tau is is um pi over two
like it's like if you draw a pi it's one
part of that
yes it's pi over two and there's a kind
of a question we were wondering at one
point
if you look at all the math formulas
that people write down
does pi usually occur as pi over two
or does it usually actually occur as pi
i'm trying to remember the answer to
this i i think it was
not pi over two is definitely less
common than just
pure pi pi there's just all kinds of
different reasons in math
why you end up with pie and uh there are
you know some of them lead to pi over
two but many of them don't uh there's
you know there's pi day uh you know
march 14th
is is pi day three one four
um and there's also tau day whatever it
is
this is tower day but that's i thought
it was 157 but that can't be right
because
yeah anyway never mind there's a there's
a tau day
or am i confusing myself here with them
uh in any case the um
the thing that um so we we tried to do
this study for one of these tau days
um and uh i don't think tao was the
winner in that case um
so i i don't know uh certainly the
notation of tau
um for pi over two is a modern you know
recent
cute notation um
let's see
oh boy there's some
all right there's a question about uh um
ah yeah why not the david asks
did feynman overestimate fredkin have
string theorists underestimated fred kim
so this is complicated because these are
you know i can tell all kinds of stories
about people who've been dead for 100
years
it's less clear um the extent to which
i should tell stories about people who
are uh you know
alive and friends of mine and so on but
but ed fredkin has had an interesting
enough life i think it deserves
to be to be told a bit and um
so ed has been a big proponent of kind
of digital physics
and kind of somehow physics is
computational
and um he's had an interesting life
and sometimes i i've known him for
oh gosh what is it 40 something years
now
and sometimes i will admit and i've
certainly
he certainly knows i think this that uh
i find
his work a bit frustrating because it's
like like he's never really
you know studied you know in in my own
life
as i've come to sort of understand
physics as a very computational kind of
thing
that was a kind of second act for me you
know
back when i was much younger i did
physics the same way most other
physicists do physics using standard
mathematical methods and so on
and uh well i used computers which was a
little unusual but but uh
basically doing physics the way that
people have learned physics for the last
hundred years or so
um ed has never really went through that
and so for him it's like
can i find an electron in a cellular
automaton you know maybe there's a way
that this
cluster of bits in a cellular automaton
is like an electron
and it's like ed that just can't work
that way you know we know enough about
physics
to know that's not how that can work now
there may be interesting ideas there and
ed has had a bunch of interesting ideas
about
sort of what computation makes possible
but this kind of very direct you know i
see this thing moving across the screen
it must be an electron
i don't think that works it's more
subtle than that there are more layers
than that
it's not such a direct kind of
correspondence
but ed's own history i think is is uh
is interesting i um see if i can you
know
he must have been let's see he's now
80-ish so uh that um
uh he um um uh
you know grew up in new york city and um
i think his
his his father was actually something of
an inventor
and polymath and writer of books about
the nature of the world and so on
but um ed himself wound up
as a student at caltech um
and uh um and uh but but dropped out
fairly quickly
and joined the air force and became a
test pilot
um and he has many stories to tell about
test piloting which are quite fun
um but uh then then he kind of um
uh uh sort of in the air force he got
assigned
to do to be involved with
the early air defense computer systems
this was in the 1950s and this was out
at lincoln labs in massachusetts
this concept of you know using that
that's like aggregating all the data
from
radar and so on and um and making them
uh and that was the early things like
the sage system
um that was uh for sort of aggregating
command and control air defense type
things
i think the thing that wound up in
cheyenne mountain
in wyoming right that's the uh
that's this big facility that's sort of
carved into the inside of a mountain
able to withstand you know uh the the
most intense nuclear war and so on i
think it's main main technological
feature
is that the whole facility is on a giant
spring so even if
even if there's a big uh nuclear
explosion somewhere on the mountain
and everything kind of has a giant
earthquake the computers will be okay
i mean i think i don't know whether
they're still running the computers from
the 1950s
somehow the way these things work in in
in some of those areas you know there's
sort of a 50-year procurement cycle or
something and that
it maybe maybe they still are probably
they're not anymore but anyways in any
case
ed got involved in in the programming
of those early computers which was not
really a thing in those days and they
were kind of like
ibm had been the the um uh the main
producer of those computers and i think
they sort of trained
some people from the air force and ed
was one of them you know how to program
the computer
um and uh i think then ed left the air
force got involved with this company
called bbn both baranika newman
which was originally i think primarily
an acoustics company
but but became very much a
computer-related company and and was
notable
for having been a key part of the
development of the arpanet that became
the internet and so on
so then then ed i don't know all the
details and i
i am this must have been 1960
very early 60s ed kind of left that
went to los angeles and started a
company called triple i
information international incorporated
which was a very creative
early kind of computer company which did
um
uh early computer graphics like it made
the the cbs
rotating eye graphic that they used as a
sort of um i don't know what they called
but the thing to start programs and so
on that was made originally
by triple i and triple i had a very
creative group of people associated with
it
um and uh that was kind of ed's thing
and uh he had a partner in that i think
the partner died
and that caused the the whole the
company to have all kinds of problems
and
and ed kind of left that um having made
a certain amount of money from triple i
one uh consequence of which was that he
bought himself this island
in the uh in the british virgin islands
and um
i i think the uh his theory was you know
this was remember this was i think this
was 1960 mid 1960s
and you know most people's theory was
the world's going to end in a giant you
know world war three
nuclear confrontation and ed had figured
out that
the um the wind patterns of the earth
mixed least if you were near the equator
like
you know in the caribbean and so on and
so you would be okay and there wouldn't
be much nuclear fallout there
even if the you know the northern
hemisphere blew itself up
with a nasty exchange of nuclear weapons
um so he decided he was going to buy
himself this island i suppose in today's
world people are
keen on new zealand and places like that
as the out-of-the-way
uh places to to own real estate and so
on
but um uh anyway ed was sort of
innovative and and uh
uh in this and got this island called
mosquito island in the british virgin
islands
um and i i visited there only once it
was in
probably 1983
maybe two 82 perhaps yeah i think 82.
um and um
it had it had many interesting features
as a as a um
uh it had a certain uh you know
the kind of the james bond villain
living on the um
on the obscure island type thing
definitely had its uh
uh had its resonance with with some
aspects of that situation
but any case the um and i remember at
the time
this was the time maybe it was a few
years after that
that uh early i i should tell more about
ed's story because that
got into the 1980s but but he he bought
this island anyway he finally
sold it to richard branson actually a
few years ago um
and uh uh it's it's um i'm sure now
it's you know it's become a it's
probably become a hotel and you'd
probably stay there
um but um uh in any case
the um back to the story of ed and his
activities
so back in triple i he kind of left
triple i
and then he got recruited to be the head
of the lab for computer science at mit
and he was very proud of the fact he
didn't have a college degree he had no
you know no academic qualifications but
yet he was being pulled in
to be the the head of this
computer science operation at mit and in
fact he was quite successful at that he
he um was
was uh along with marvin minsky and
other people
with some kind of and that was all
connected to the ai lab and it was kind
of these
these two different pieces um but uh you
know he sort of successfully ran that
uh for quite a number of years um
and uh one of the things that he was
always keen on
was he kind of had this notion and i
think it came
i think he told me he started on this in
like 1958
this idea that somehow cellular automata
will like physics
and he looked at two-dimensional
cellular automata and he uh
he wrote programs for them i think on
the pdp one
he um at bbn maybe 1961
to something like that he was writing
programs for
to do certain kinds of simple
two-dimensional cellular automata
and he kind of had this conviction that
somehow physics must be like computers
and uh but like you know things like
two-dimensional cellular automata
um and uh when he was at mit
uh he would teach classes about this
kind of thing and so on
and he also had another idea which was
computing doesn't have to be
uh could be reversible you could have
something where
usually when you have a you know an and
gate or something
it's like it has two inputs it has one
output once you have the output you
can't reverse it and say what the inputs
were
but what if you had a gate that had two
inputs and two outputs
well then you could in principle if the
if the gate did the right things you
could in principle reverse any
computation
and so you kind of had that idea von
neumann had had the idea
that every computation must be sort of
for some kind of thermodynamic
must be irreversible there must be a
fundamental irreversibility to
computation
there's a chap called ralph landauer
actually a term uh
at ibm who was very much into studying
that sort of thermodynamics of
computation
between him and a person called charles
bennett also an mi at
uh ibm and ed fredkin that kind of crowd
uh in the 90s by the 1970s that sort of
convinced themselves at least
that computation could be reversible
that's of course true and now there are
fredkin
gates which are uh which people talk
about in quantum computing
they are examples of gates i think
they're three to three gates if i
remember correctly
that um have this feature that they can
be run reversibly so to speak
but that was kind of one of the ideas
that ed was like computation can be
reversible
but the technical details of that were
sometimes a bit
uh elusive for him and and later on got
filled in by other people
but um you know ed
i guess by the time i knew him which was
beginning of the 1980s
um he had been he was no longer so much
affiliated with mit
and um he uh uh had become involved in
investing in lots of companies
and there was one in particular that was
a workstation company
that made a machine called the perk perq
which was an early workstation computer
this is back um
in the early 80s and i remember that one
of the more amusing features was that
the
this is a british company i guess is
that right
um it somehow had some
no it was no no it must have been a
boston-based company because it was
three rivers
computer corporation was was i think the
the name of the company
and um yeah i think it was boston based
but that's right it made this big deal
with the british government to supply
perk computers
um in the uk and that was something
edward had been much involved in but one
of the
one of the sort of footnote features of
the perk computer is
operates at 100 humidity can be used on
tropical island the british virgin
islands without all the electronics
uh you know shorting out and so on and
that was uh that was kind of a
an ed special feature of that computer
and also ran cellular automata very
nicely on a nice bitmap display
well in any case the um uh
um subsequently
um ed uh dick feynman always used to
enjoy ed because
ed is a very um he's a he's a colorful
person who tells many colorful stories
some of which are even correct um and uh
the um
and has many kind of wild ideas so to
speak
um and uh i would say he's been a user
of our
language since it began and uh he's
always coming up with you should do this
you should do that and
they're very they're always very um uh
let's say it's like well yes you know
yes we could do that it will take 20
years to do that ad
you know it's it's a big difficult thing
to do it's not just one of these oh yeah
well
we'll happen to do that and usually the
things were sort of
going in that direction and so on but i
i certainly think um
uh ed is very is very much on the on the
sort of the big ideas some
uh direction of things but i remember
some years after that
uh being in the slightly peculiar
situation that ed was
becoming a visiting professor at boston
university
and so um i got roped in to write a
recommendation letter for ed and i i
seem to remember
that i wrote something like uh you know
is not
you know is has all kinds of interesting
ideas but you must recognize
that he is much more used to boardroom
presentations than academic lectures
and so his style of presenting is not
what you expect of an academic
um actually i remember back in the early
80s i remember ed
wanting to make some deal with me where
i would teach him how to write an
academic paper
and he would teach me how to uh run
companies and so on
we never executed on this deal it turned
out i seem to
figure out more or less how to run
companies and i i kind of stopped
writing academic papers so
i perhaps wouldn't have been the best
tutor on on writing academic papers
um but anyway so that that's a
little bit on on the story of that i
mean in a sense
ed has pushed for this idea of you know
the universe is like a cellular
automaton
which i just don't think is correct um
but the idea that the universe is
somehow fundamentally computational
i do think is correct and i have to say
that in some ways
the pushing of what i thought was an
overly simplistic theory
probably slowed some things down for me
at least for a number of years
because it's like no that isn't right
you know it's
let's not go down that path because it's
just not right
and that you know understanding that the
the story that we now understand
about these kind of hypergraphs and
things which are much
floppier kinds of structures than the
rigid grid of a cellular automaton
and so on but um i think uh
um ed has some
uh i mean unfortunately he's as
as will happened to us all well i
suppose it
should happen to us all gets old but i
think um
uh um ed has uh
is just has an awful lot of interesting
stories to tell about um
oh ed because of his his role in the air
force
he um he ended up starting an air taxi
service
and um one of the things that happened
with their taxi service he had all kinds
of interesting clients
and so ed would i guess when sort of
things fell through for his pilots would
be
flying the planes himself and um there's
just an awful lot of interesting
characters
um who he uh met through
you know running an air taxi service in
the new england area so to speak
and then being consultant for ibm and
digital equipment corporation and so on
and just a lot of interesting stories
about um the history of the computer
industry
and in in some cases things where
um ed will certainly tell stories about
how various critical decisions made by
these various companies were either
followed aired or more likely didn't
follow ed but should have followed in so
to speak in what he told them
and uh i it's it's often hard to tell
you know when you
advise some company particularly a
larger company and you're like
i told you to do this and then five
years later well they do that or they
don't do that
it's like the connection between what
you said and what they did
is often extremely hard to trace um
but uh they're they're sort of
interesting stories there
so um okay there are a few other
questions let me um
oh you see look at this somebody's
pointing out tower day is june 28
6 28. so i got this wrong towers too pie
why does that make sense i thought tau
was a a half of a pie
my apologies i i i hope i was at least
uh
clear on the fact that i wasn't clear in
in describing that
um this question from philip here did i
work much with murray gel man
any shareable stories well uh yeah i
knew marigold man quite well
um i think i actually wrote a piece
um sort of obituary piece about him that
probably has more detail than i'll say
here
but um uh murray was for me
in some ways a very frustrating
character uh a great physicist
who had done his great work quite early
in his life by the time i knew him
his great work was kind of in the past
as it turned out
i mean i first interacted with murray
when i was probably what
17 years old i think and i was in
england
and i was sort of going to go to
graduate school somewhere
and i get this call one day from you
know from murray gilman
telling me oh you should come to caltech
for graduate school
well in those days it wasn't like cell
phones it wasn't it was quite
coincidental that he actually managed to
successfully
you know uh find me at a phone that
could be called
at but anyway he did and i have to say i
remember that
conversation as being i think murray was
a little bit
uh perhaps put out that he expected
uh me to be a little bit more sort of
star struck by the fact that he bothered
to make the phone call
than perhaps i was and and maybe i was
too bratty a 17 year old i don't really
know
but um uh that was my first encounter
with murray
and then sorry i did go to caltech for
graduate school
uh you know a few months after that um
and uh i remember i remember the first
time i met murray
was you know a few days after i showed
up there and
this is very typical murray situation
okay so there i was
um and uh murray
you know wants to say something sort of
he says
it must be a tremendous culture shock
coming from you know from england to
california
and then realizes looks at me and
realizes you know i'm wearing this
bright yellow shirt and these sandals
and things and i'm kind of looking
very indigenous so to speak or very at
least californian
um at that point and um and so he's then
then it's very typical murray i mean he
kind of is sort of embarrassed he said
the wrong thing
and um uh and and then
goes off in some other direction but but
um i mean murray
was a um uh
was somebody who just
had done great work in mathematical
physics inventing quarks
inventing strangeness um figuring out
uh sort of really pushing uh gauge
theories early on
um but then
somehow i think to some extent
the kind of uh
when as i say when i knew him sort of
the years when he was the absolutely
golden person of physics where basically
every major idea in physics came from
murray those ideas have passed
those those years have passed and he
never really managed to get a good
second act
and i think it drove him really it
really upset him that he wasn't
seeing you know what does he do next so
to speak and so
you know when i knew him he was quite
bitter i would say about
about a lot of the you know people don't
understand that he murray
had done this and this and this and this
and this which he had
but you know the the nature of sort of
the academic enterprise is rather
tends to be rather unforgiving about
those kinds of things
and i think uh you know i remember but
murray would do kind of silly things
like he would i remember one time
i'm talking to him about this thing
called the beta function which is a
feature of of uh
quantum field theory and um you know
it's like
the name by the by the this was in what
1978 or something like that
people would call the beta function the
beta function that was what it was
called okay
well it turns out and i i knew this
perfectly well that murray had written
an early paper with a person called
francis lowe
back in maybe 1956 where he had
introduced a version of the beta
function
but he called it the psi function it had
a slightly different
definition but it was you know the the
the sort of the
effective equivalent of the beta
function okay so we have this whole long
conversation
where murray is is um uh is pretending
he doesn't understand a word i'm
saying you know i'm talking about beta
functions and this and that and the
other
and eventually murray says oh
you mean the psi function you know why
didn't you just say that
and it's like look you know
yes i mean i understand that that um uh
and perhaps you know in
perhaps in more modern times i would
have made that clarification for him but
he knew perfectly well what i was
talking about
and unknown from the beginning of the
conversation but was just kind of
uh doing this kind of branding
presentation so to speak
um about that i think um so you know he
could be a bit frustrating in those
kinds of ways
i would say that um his uh
uh later on he um
uh kind of he was much involved with the
santa fe institute and the whole
uh sort of complexity direction that i
had kind of
uh i think initiated for those guys but
murray really took that on a very
sort of serious way and and had been was
like
complexity is everything and so on and i
you know i would try to talk to murray
about this stuff
uh and he'd known a bunch of the work
that i've done in the 1980s about these
things
and we talked about it a bunch of times
although he never really seemed to care
that much about it
um but uh by that point murray was sort
of
working on complexity and and hoping
that the sort of golden touch that he'd
had in particle physics back in the
1950s and early 1960s
would somehow uh kind of uh you know
would somehow adapt itself to complexity
and
it just wasn't working it just was like
let's make a definition of the concept
of complexity using mathematical physics
it just doesn't work it's a different
kind of thing
and uh it didn't help that murray tended
to be very
judgmental about lots of kinds of things
for example one of his
probably less endearing features was
that you know he would talk about
physics
there's particle physics that was the
thing he was really big on and there's
what he used to call squalid state
physics
which meant what's now called condensed
matter physics
used to be called solid-state physics
but he would always call it squalid
state physics
which was like seemed like a needless
kind of uh uh poke and um
i think that and that was kind of again
quintessential murray
but i think that the um um
and murray would be very um uh murray
was a very erudite person
uh particularly interested in kind of
human languages and things like this
and he would always you know he had the
misfortune of working
you know basically right next door to
dick fineman
and the two of them they had a very uh
frenemy type relationship i mean they
had done some work together in the 1950s
that was quite successful
but then they were you know always at
each other's throats i mean
each of them told me terrible stories
about the other one
and um uh you know i think murray was
just you know
dick feynman was was always uh you know
kind of playing the
oh i'm just the simple guy from from uh
from the bronx or whatever
and they both came from new york city um
but uh
the new york city area and murray was
like you know i'm the sophisticated you
know pronounce every foreign word
correctly
and and feynman was always the i'm just
gonna say it the way the way i
think it should sound and i don't care
about all this erudite stuff
and so that that that led to quite a
quite a tension there
but um you know murray would have this
feature
that um and again it was it was very
very
badly conceived for murray given his
personality
that you know he's very into words and
when he would meet people
one of the things he would always do is
try and explain the origin of their
names
and this is just such a bad idea because
if there's
one word or one thing where you're
likely to know something about the
history it's your own name
and so he would you know i i saw many of
these cases where he would be telling
people
you know your name is a version of
something and you know high
slavic of this that and the other and
the person will say
murray that's just nonsense you know my
name was made up by some immigration
official at ellis island you know
two generations ago or something and and
and then murray would be very kind of uh
embarrassed and um uh it was just a very
terrible
situation because he kept on setting
himself up for
you know uh for something where where he
would be embarrassed by by sort of not
being the um
uh by not knowing what was going on and
i think
in his later years he worked you know he
he
was very much involved with the santa fe
institute and worked on complexity
and there was a sort of terrible thing
that happened because he was going to
write
a book um a um uh
the um uh which was
i kind of hoped to be on autobiography
because i thought there was a lot of
really interesting material
murray was a perfectionistic writer took
him a very long time to write text
the text he wrote have a habit of being
a bit wooden
through over over rewriting i would say
but um
he you know he he set about writing this
book but he said no it's not going to be
an autobiography it's going to be a
great
book of new science the problem was that
he didn't really have the new science to
feed into it
he went through a couple of editors uh
you know he said it gave him a heart
attack you know doing
the sort of the stress of trying to do
this book it had been set up by an agent
we both know um both knew um
who um you know had got him a big
advance for this book and so he was like
committed he's going to write this book
and what's the book going to be and i
was like for goodness sake make an
autobiography
that's the book that you should write
but no he he wanted to write a book of
you know primary science and you know in
the end wrote this book called the quark
and the jaguar which i'm afraid is not a
terribly good book
and um is uh uh
had um and that was um
uh and it sort of almost killed him
writing that book
which is just a bad story um and i think
you know he did things like
again typical murray uh this was told to
me
originally i was tipped off to this by a
person called georges vig
george's vibe long time friend of mine
was the other inventor of quarks
along with murray george had been a
graduate student at cal tech
and kind of came up with the sort of
idea of quarks
uh sort of independent of murray and
there's kind of a long time
story but between of of what happened
there
but um uh anyway
george took me after the fact that
murray had told him
oh i'm not putting people's names in the
index
so that they'll have to read through the
book to find out if they're in there or
not
and that was of course now that there
are ebooks it's a bit of a different
story but um
uh that was sort of again a typical kind
of murray strange murray move
but um uh in a sense murray
was uh he also had tended to have a
habit
of he would glom on to particularly
people
who he thought were you know promising
and unfortunately his his choice of
promising people and his choice of
people
who he thought were unpromising turned
out to be often
very wide of the mark and um oh for
example
a number of physicists steve weinberg is
one particular one who comes to mind
you know murray was like always you know
attacking oh he doesn't have anything to
contribute
well turned out he contributed a lot
maybe he's uh
uh i'm not sure i always agree with him
but but um
uh you know he certainly uh contributed
plenty to physics
um and then murray would be very keen on
these other people
who who who never really went very far
and i was
i was a bit uh afraid because murray was
always a big proponent of mine
and at least in the early years um and
so i always thought that was a little
bit scary because it's like
um you know i look at these examples of
murray has been a big proponent of this
and this and this
and it didn't work out very well but um
i mean murray
had many things murray invented i mean
not only
quarks and strangeness he was also very
involved in qcd
the detailed story of the origination of
qcd is kind of complicated but murray
was definitely
involved uh string theory to some extent
also
to some extent that's again a
complicated story i mean he long
supported
john schwartz who was sort of one of the
people who kept string theory alive
from its origination in the 1960s to its
kind of rebirth
in in the super gravity world of the um
of the
when was it mid to late 1980s um
and uh so in any case that that was um
um uh but yes i i
um i would say
uh i could tell many more stories about
murray but i would say that the um
the thing one of my personal takeaways
from murray
is you know it's cool to have successes
early in life
in science or something the management
of a career after that is a difficult
matter
and it's something where i always felt
murray had really wanted a second act
i mean he became you know he was on
corporate boards and he would try to be
sort of a a pooh bar of science he
wasn't terribly good at that
because he would tend to be rather
opinionated
um i mean you know many of us are
opinionated
but you know the question is whether we
put ourselves in situations where
that is not really what's wanted and and
murray did
and and so people would be like oh no we
don't want murray involved in this thing
and then murray will be all upset
because
he felt he was being rejected from this
thing and so on so it was a
it was a you know he never really found
a great second act
he was a very uh you know his his
eradication
was you know that there should have been
a second act but he never really quite
figured out what it was
um and that perhaps if he had been a a
less labored writer
he would have been a um a sort of a a
great writer
of of um of grand sort of pictures of of
uh
science the arts and everything because
he had a pretty pretty broad knowledge
of lots of kinds of things
um he was uh very into archaeology very
into languages
et cetera et cetera et cetera um but
somehow he never managed i mean it's
sort of interesting he never managed to
pull together like his knowledge of
linguistics and languages
as a matter of you know this is the
pronunciation of this word
in some obscure language that was very
good
his knowledge of kind of what's the big
picture of how do we think about you
know how language works and so on
i don't think he ever really got to that
and i remember having
discussions with him sort of late in his
life about um
about those kinds of things which uh you
know i have a particular point of view
at least from having designed
computational languages
for a long time and i think uh i
i always felt that murray was was not
hadn't wasn't really at the starting
date in terms of understanding the
issues there
i'm not sure we've understood them yet
but um i just didn't think
he was going in the right direction
there all right well i should wrap up
very soon here maybe one
um last uh
um all right i'm gonna i'm gonna take
one last one
that's kind of a funky one which is what
is my opinion on the resurgence of ufos
um that's a fun one
um what is my opinion on resurgence i
mean i've certainly noticed
the fact that people are talking more
about
you know air force sightings of ufos and
all this kind of thing
i think it's sort of an interesting
question what um
you know it raises all kinds of
philosophical questions about
what is an alien you know if it is it an
alien spacecraft does it have to have
come from outer space to be a
ufo does it you know if you have some
weird new meteorological phenomenon
that's never been seen before
how does that relate to being a ufo-like
thing
um i think that's that's a a um uh
you know and that which is not explained
what is its origin
uh you know do you say uh this this
thing we can't explain
must be of supernatural origins or do
you say well we just didn't manage to
figure out enough about science to
explain that
that's a you know that's a continuing
kind of question that comes up in lots
of places
now in terms of this question of of sort
of
what's known in the world and suppressed
as knowledge
that's an interesting question and
occasionally uh you know in different
countries there are different rules
about
you know things which are sort of which
are born secret
versus things which are only secret if
you basically made a contract with the
government that says you'll keep them
secret and so there are you know there
are different things and over the course
of my life i've certainly learned a
bunch of things
that um uh you know are have sort of
fallen out of being
where i you know they're not things
where i'm signed up to keep them secret
but they've
kind of fallen out of different kinds of
things um and you sort of learn these
things which are kind of um
uh knowledge that's kind of been
suppressed in some way or another
and sometimes that knowledge is kind of
interesting because some of the things
i've learned along those lines
about scientific technological kinds of
things are like
uh you know people say well yes it was
kept secret because
it's so weird and kind of hokey
that and not about ufos but about sort
of how various kinds of technologies
work and how to actually do this or that
thing
oh you know you uh you use you know some
some kind of food and you smear it on a
submarine or something
and that works great that's not a real
one um the uh
uh you know that works great as a way to
reduce the dragon submarine or something
like this
uh not a real one but um uh you know but
but
but nobody if you told the world you
know you smear butter on the submarine
to get it to go faster
everybody would just laugh at you so
it's better to just keep it a secret
but i don't know the extent to which um
you know that there are these things
where there was you know
some something it's it's always an
interesting question the things which
were
over the course of history and we
certainly know them going back
you know centuries things which uh this
was a
government secret so to speak and what
happened to it
or this was you know a piece of
cryptography that nobody's going to let
you know nobody's going to decode that
um and uh you know when you know
how long can these things be kept secret
and
you know when you decode it is it even
interesting and so on
so i i don't know what um i have um
uh no profound insight probably
although i think it's sort of an
interesting question how much
how much hidden knowledge is there in
the world if you go back
n years let's say you go back 100 years
is there still any hidden knowledge in
the world that is there stuff that was
known
to let's say governments and so on but
has never been
brought out in the public eye um is
there stuff
that um you know if you go less time
than that second world war
time frame there's still some stuff
that's still classified from that period
of time
um and uh you know what uh
as you go closer to the present day
what's the rate of kind of
undisclosed knowledge so to speak and
particularly when it comes to scientific
knowledge
what is there that's disclosed versus
not disclosed
and i think you know two big areas
nuclear weapons and cryptography
were two big areas coming out of the
second world war cryptography
kind of stayed secret longer and
uh you know there are pieces i think of
the story of cryptography and mobile too
which are still
not i mean that some were only very
recently declassified
i remember just to tell a funny story
perhaps an interesting story
so when i was when i was young uh alan
turin was not a particularly famous
person
um but uh the
and and certainly the work that he did
at bletchley park during world war ii
was
was completely unknown completely
unknown and in fact
the only rumor that i sort of heard
picked up in the 1970s
well with two things i picked up the
sort of rumor maybe
turing had been involved with bletchley
park maybe he invented
the codes that were used by the british
maybe he'd been bumped off because they
didn't want
people to know what codes they'd been
using because they wanted to keep them
secret
that was what i so that was the rumor
mill around kind of the oxford-ish
area meanwhile actually when i was
younger than that
there was a classics professor i knew an
older fellow
who um again i didn't know what he did
during world war ii i only knew
that he'd done something notable in
world war ii but didn't know what it was
and it had been something about you know
writing leaflets i mean one part that
i'd heard was sort of
writing leaflets that will be dropped
from planes over berlin
to you know over germany to kind of tell
the enemy why they're doomed type thing
but but in fact but but he told me um
he told me one thing was he said oh yeah
there was this chap i knew during the
war
named alan turing and he's an
interesting chap you know the stuff
you're talking about it's
you know it seems sounds like kind of
thing he was interested in that was one
thing
second thing was you know we talked to
me about
you know things about latin and whatever
and every time
the word ultra would show up in any
piece of latin
he would sort of repeat ultra ultra
ultra ultra
just keep repeating this word why
no idea but i remembered that and of
course
many years later i discovered when the
whole bletchley park story was
declassified there was this thing called
ultra
at bletchley park it was a code name and
this guy had worked on that
and this was you know he wasn't he was
going to be proper
and not disclose any secret to the
random 12 year old or whatever it was
but um you know but on the other hand he
wanted to kind of pass on
this piece of knowledge and leave this
little little piece thing hanging out
there this morsel
hanging out there and he had a correct
calculation that i remember
this kind of eccentricity years later
anyway i just mentioned
one thing i was at a in 2012 it was the
centenary of alan turing's birth and
there were a bunch of events that um uh
were around that i was at one in
cambridge where a person was talking
about
their work at bletchley park and this
person had um
didn't know nobody told them that the
work they'd done had been
declassified it was only declassified in
the 1990s
and this person had a whole career and i
think advertising
after their time at bletchley park and
by the point that where they were giving
this talk
they were they were quite old um but
anyway they'd worked at bletchley park
and they were just describing how uh and
i think this was the first time they
talked about this stuff because it
wasn't
they didn't know nobody nobody went back
and said oh we should go tell
all these people that the work they did
in world war ii is now declassified
um but uh he was working on on this
um uh this sort of super secret
um uh network of of um
um of of uh
cryptographic devices that the nazis had
not like enigma which was quite widely
distributed among their field commanders
this was just for sort of central
command posts or something
and there were a small number of nodes
of this thing but apparently due to some
clerk in somewhere in greece or
something had resent a message twice
which is a deadly thing to do
in the cryptography business um anyway
they managed to decode this and this guy
was
was sort of describing the fact that um
uh uh you know having got to the end of
the message you know he was decoding
pieces of this message
and you know at the end it says you know
the message is signed you know adolf
hitler fura
and that's kind of the um you know
that's the point where he knows he's
correctly decoded the message
but it's sort of a a remarkable thing to
have managed to pull that out
from from this and then that it was it
was secret that these
this crypto system had uh even existed
and second had been had been broken um
it was secret for for many many many
years
and so you know there's this whole
question about you know what is the
decay time of secrets what should it be
that's a different question
uh what is it interesting question you
know
if there are sort of weird ufo-like
things that um
um uh you know the you know
would they have been kept secret for 50
years 70 years whatever it is
um i don't know i i think that the
number as i say the number of secrets
from world war ii time frame
is is definitely dwindling to to almost
nothing and
in the areas that i'm aware of like
nuclear weapons and cryptography
all right i think it's um it's time to
wrap up here before i
before i say anything otherwise to too
horrifying
um but uh uh actually i'm about to go
to my day job and uh actually have a
live stream coming up there
about uh wolf and language design but um
lots of questions i didn't get to today
um which i'd love to get to another time
and uh
look forward to being with you again uh
for this
uh history of science and technology in
two weeks
okay so thanks for thanks for joining us